iPhone 5c is built on a foundation of features that people know and love.
With a beautiful four-inch retina display,...
...blazing-fast performance and console level graphics from the a6 chip,...
...the eight-megapixel iSight camera and an impressive battery life.
And now we've added more LTE bands than any other smartphone in the world.
And we've given it a new FaceTime HD camera for even better FaceTime calls and self-portraits.
Beyond that, it comes with iOS 7...
...which includes new features like Control Center, AirDrop and iTunes Radio.
Combined with a ton of other great features,...
...IOS 7 creates an experience that's even simpler, more useful and more enjoyable.
iOS 7 is designed to complement the iPhone 5c beautifully.
The wallpapers are color-matched to the exterior...
...and the translucency inherent in iOS 7 carries this color through everything you do.
This is just another great example of how we design and engineer our products in concert.
It really is the only way that we believe provides the right experience.